This holiday season, Instacart is bringing magic to the people who make it magic for others. Get delivery and deals on everything you need this season. Whether it's a last-minute holiday decor emergency, coverage for the holiday party, or just avoiding going out in the cold, Instacart is here. Plus, with no markups at select retailers, you get in-store prices on grocery, electronics, beauty, toys, and more. Download the Instacart app to get a little magic delivered today. Instacart, groceries that over deliver. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together, and we're best friends.
This holiday season, Instacart is bringing magic to the people who make it magic for others. Get delivery and deals on everything you need this season. Whether it's a last-minute holiday decor emergency, coverage for the holiday party, or just avoiding going out in the cold, Instacart is here. Plus, with no markups at select retailers, you get in-store prices on grocery, electronics, beauty, toys, and more. Download the Instacart app to get a little magic delivered today. Instacart, groceries that over deliver. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together, and we're best friends.|||这个辞旧迎新的节日季，Instacart 正为那些为别人创造魔法的人带来魔法。在这个季节，获取你所需一切的配送服务与优惠。无论是最后一刻的节日装饰紧急情况、节日派对的备用物资，还是仅仅为了避免外出受冻，Instacart 都在这里。此外，在部分零售商处无溢价，让你以店面价格买到杂货、电子产品、美妆、玩具等各种商品。下载 Instacart App，今天就把一点魔法送到家。Instacart，让杂货配送超越期待。服务费、除外条款和适用条款另行规定。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week, we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. This is cool cat that I hang out with at Christmas Never knew how to pronounce his last name Good king when Silas looked out On the feast of Stephen When the snow lay round about Deep and crisp and even
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week, we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. This is cool cat that I hang out with at Christmas Never knew how to pronounce his last name Good king when Silas looked out On the feast of Stephen When the snow lay round about Deep and crisp and even|||现在，我们专门为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是 Office Lady 6.0。这是我圣诞节一起玩的酷猫，以前从不知道他的姓怎么发音。贤君温塞勒斯向外望去，在史蒂芬的瞻礼日，当雪铺满四周，深厚、清脆且平整。
Brightly shown the moon that night Though the frost was cruel When a poor man came in sight Gathering winter fuel Woo-hoo! Happy holidays, everyone! Happy holidays! We are listening to a song on the album, A Swing and Little Christmas by Jane Lynch and Kate Flannery, our guest here today. Hey!
Brightly shown the moon that night Though the frost was cruel When a poor man came in sight Gathering winter fuel Woo-hoo! Happy holidays, everyone! Happy holidays! We are listening to a song on the album, A Swing and Little Christmas by Jane Lynch and Kate Flannery, our guest here today. Hey!|||那天晚上的月光明亮照耀，尽管严霜残酷，当一个穷人进入视线，收集冬天的燃料。呜呼！大家节日快乐！节日快乐！我们正在听一张专辑里的歌，是由简·林奇和今天我们的嘉宾凯特·弗兰纳里带来的《A Swing and Little Christmas》。嘿！
Kate, welcome. Oh, my gosh, you are putting me in the holiday spirit. I'll try not to sing everything today. So good to see you guys. It's so good to see you. Thank you. Thank you for joining us on our holiday chit-chat episode. Here's what we're going to do today, everyone.
Kate, welcome. Oh, my gosh, you are putting me in the holiday spirit. I'll try not to sing everything today. So good to see you guys. It's so good to see you. Thank you. Thank you for joining us on our holiday chit-chat episode. Here's what we're going to do today, everyone.|||凯特，欢迎。哦，天哪，你让我感受到了节日的氛围。我今天会尽量克制不把所有歌都唱出来。很高兴见到你们。很高兴见到你。谢谢。谢谢你加入我们的节日闲聊期。大家听好，我们今天要这样做。
We are going to talk about the holidays on the office. we're going to talk about holidays in general, all kinds of other stuff. We're so excited to have you, Kate, and you have dressed for the occasion. You took the assignment. You're like, I'm on it, ladies. You look amazing. Thank you so much. I do not phone it in, even on a podcast.
We are going to talk about the holidays on the office. we're going to talk about holidays in general, all kinds of other stuff. We're so excited to have you, Kate, and you have dressed for the occasion. You took the assignment. You're like, I'm on it, ladies. You look amazing. Thank you so much. I do not phone it in, even on a podcast.|||我们要聊聊《办公室》里的节日。我们要聊聊一般的节日，还有各种别的事情。凯特，我们非常高兴你能来，而且你为今天的场合精心打扮了。你完美完成了任务。你的态度就像是：女士们，交给我吧。你看起来棒极了。非常感谢。我做事从来不敷衍，哪怕是在播客里。
I bring it 300%. You're coming in hot, lady. I love anyone that embraces a theme. I was like, you know what? Come on. We're talking about Christmas. I mean, every Christmas party, if anybody's ever worked in any kind of establishment that had, a party once a year in December, you know, you know what's going on. We got to celebrate.
I bring it 300%. You're coming in hot, lady. I love anyone that embraces a theme. I was like, you know what? Come on. We're talking about Christmas. I mean, every Christmas party, if anybody's ever worked in any kind of establishment that had, a party once a year in December, you know, you know what's going on. We got to celebrate.|||我付出了百分之三百的努力。你太热情了，女士。我喜欢任何拥抱主题的人。我当时想，你知道吗？来吧。我们在谈论圣诞节。我的意思是，每一个圣诞派对，如果有人曾在任何每年十二月会办一次派对的机构工作过，你知道的，你知道是怎么回事。我们得庆祝一下。
You got your outfit. I mean, I might have worn red velvet pants to a Christmas party one time. You got your cute little. I have my Christmas sweater on. Your Christmas sweater with your mini Cooper with a Christmas tree on top. You too could wear this if you went to Marshall's last year. And Jenna's got her black watch plaid jacket with Christmas earrings. My Christmas earrings that you said look like Christmas earrings that Meredith wore. Meredith wore. They look like Christmas balls that she literally like the tiny ones that you take off the tree
You got your outfit. I mean, I might have worn red velvet pants to a Christmas party one time. You got your cute little. I have my Christmas sweater on. Your Christmas sweater with your mini Cooper with a Christmas tree on top. You too could wear this if you went to Marshall's last year. And Jenna's got her black watch plaid jacket with Christmas earrings. My Christmas earrings that you said look like Christmas earrings that Meredith wore. Meredith wore. They look like Christmas balls that she literally like the tiny ones that you take off the tree|||你穿好了衣服。我的意思是，我曾经可能在一场圣诞派对上穿过红色天鹅绒裤子。你有你可爱的小……我穿着我的圣诞毛衣。你的圣诞毛衣上有印着一辆顶着圣诞树的迷你库珀。如果你去年去过马歇尔百货，你也能穿这个。珍娜穿着她的黑表格子夹克，戴着圣诞耳环。我的圣诞耳环，你说是梅雷迪思戴过的那种圣诞耳环。梅雷迪思戴过。它们看起来就像圣诞球，就像你从树上摘下来的那种小小的球， literally。
and you try to put in your ear when you're younger and realize it's a bad idea. The same Christmas balls that Angela Martin smashed in the snow and screeched. Yeah. Your tart and jacket is super cute. Okay. Lady, you gave me that tartan jacket. I know, I know I did. Do you remember because you compliment it today as if you'd never seen it before?
and you try to put in your ear when you're younger and realize it's a bad idea. The same Christmas balls that Angela Martin smashed in the snow and screeched. Yeah. Your tart and jacket is super cute. Okay. Lady, you gave me that tartan jacket. I know, I know I did. Do you remember because you compliment it today as if you'd never seen it before?|||当你年轻的时候，你试着把它塞进耳朵里，然后意识到这是个糟糕的主意。就是安吉拉·马丁在雪地里砸碎并尖叫的那些圣诞球。是的。你的格子呢夹克超级可爱。好吧。女士，那件格子呢夹克是你送我的。我知道，我知道是我送的。你还记得吗，因为你今天夸它的时候，就好像你从来没见过它一样？
No, I do. We have matching ones. I bought myself one as well. You both have great taste. Thank you. Our do I. Right now, because that's what we're thinking. So let's say it.
No, I do. We have matching ones. I bought myself one as well. You both have great taste. Thank you. Our do I. Right now, because that's what we're thinking. So let's say it.|||不，我记得。我们有情侣款。我自己也买了一件。你们俩的品味都很好。谢谢。我也有。现在，因为我们就是这么想的。所以我们说出来吧。
But it's true. They're so cute. Well, listen, let's get to it. We're so excited to have you. Thank you, guys. I'm so excited to be here. Office ladies forever. That's right.
But it's true. They're so cute. Well, listen, let's get to it. We're so excited to have you. Thank you, guys. I'm so excited to be here. Office ladies forever. That's right.|||但这确实是真的。它们太可爱了。好吧，听着，我们开始吧。我们很高兴你能来。谢谢你们，伙计们。我很高兴能来到这里。办公室女士永远在一起。没错。
And we are going to kick things off with a question from Cindy. Let's hear from her. Hi, this is Cindy from Fort Worth. And I'd love to hear how you get ready for the holidays. All right. How do we get ready for the holidays, ladies? Well, for me, I actually tour every holiday, every December. Well, actually, right after Thanksgiving.
And we are going to kick things off with a question from Cindy. Let's hear from her. Hi, this is Cindy from Fort Worth. And I'd love to hear how you get the holidays. All right. How do we get ready for the holidays, ladies? Well, for me, I actually tour every holiday, every December. Well, actually, right after Thanksgiving.|||接下来，我们将以辛迪的一个问题拉开序幕。听听她的声音。嗨，我是来自沃斯堡的辛迪。我想听听你们是如何为节日做准备的。好的。女士们，我们是如何为节日做准备的？嗯，对我来说，其实我每个节日、每个十二月都会去巡演。嗯，实际上，就在感恩节刚过。
So I have to put my stuff up before Thanksgiving or late Thanksgiving night. I tour with Jane Lynch because we did a Christmas album 10 years ago. And so we just, you know, keep like we're very busy in December. We're bringing Christmas to people. It's a huge responsibility. It's so great, though. Your show is wonderful. I have been.
So I have to put my stuff up before Thanksgiving or late Thanksgiving night. I tour with Jane Lynch because we did a Christmas album 10 years ago. And so we just, you know, keep like we're very busy in December. We're bringing Christmas to people. It's a huge responsibility. It's so great, though. Your show is wonderful. I have been.|||所以我必须在感恩节之前或感恩节深夜把东西挂好。我和简·林奇一起巡演，因为我们十年前做过一张圣诞专辑。所以我们只是，你知道，保持着……我们在十二月非常忙。我们把圣诞节带给人们。这是一项巨大的责任。不过真的很棒。你们的演出太棒了。我去过。
It's such a blast. Yeah, like I did a Christmas concert. It's our album, A Swinging Little Christmas, if you can't see it in person. But you know what? But it's fun. I feel like it forces me to do it early because I always want to come home and I would feel terrible if my place didn't look like Christmas when I got home. So I have to step it up. You have to decorate before you go on tour. I have to because I'd be so bummed when I came home and be like, oh. Also, your tour is how other people can get ready for the holidays. This is true. And people do. Yeah, usually we're like the first thing that they're seeing for the holidays because we literally start the day after Thanksgiving. I play your CD. I still have a CD. You might not have to get a new car. An album.
It's such a blast. Yeah, like I did a Christmas concert. It's our album, A Swinging Little Christmas, if you can't see it in person. But you know what? But it's fun. I feel like it forces me to do it early because I always want to come home and I would feel terrible if my place didn't look like Christmas when I got home. So I have to step it up. You have to decorate before you go on tour. I have to because I'd be so bummed when I came home and be like, oh. Also, your tour is how other people can get ready for the holidays. This is true. And people do. Yeah, usually we're like the first thing that they're seeing for the holidays because we literally start the day after Thanksgiving. I play your CD. I still have a CD. You might not have to get a new car. An album.|||这太刺激了。是的，就像我办了一场圣诞音乐会。如果你不能亲眼看到，那就是我们的专辑《A Swinging Little Christmas》。但你知道吗？但这很有趣。我觉得这迫使我早点做准备，因为我总是想回家，如果我回家时我的住处看起来不像过圣诞节，我会觉得很难受。所以我必须加快进度。你必须在巡演前装饰好。我必须这么做，因为如果我回家时发现没装饰好，我会超级沮丧。而且，你们的巡演正是其他人为节日做准备的方式。这倒也是。人们确实如此。是的，通常我们就像是他们看到的关于节日的第一个节目，因为我们实际上从感恩节的第二天就开始了。我放你的CD。我还有CD。你可能不需要买新车。一张专辑。
I played your Christmas album, I should say. You know what I mean? Yes. Because we're on Spotify and iTunes, but it's so great. It's fun. It's fun to listen to. I know. I'm just like, I actually have it on vinyl too, you guys. Oh.
I played your Christmas album, I should say. You know what I mean? Yes. Because we're on Spotify and iTunes, but it's so great. It's fun. It's fun to listen to. I know. I'm just like, I actually have it on vinyl too, you guys. Oh.|||我应该说，我播放了你们的圣诞专辑。你知道我的意思吗？是的。因为我们在 Spotify 和 iTunes 上都有，但这真的很棒。很有趣。听起来很有趣。我知道。我只想说，其实我也有黑胶唱片版的，伙计们。哦。
Limited edition on vinyl. Oh, can I get one of those? Because we play records on Christmas morning. Yeah. Let me talk to my people. Talk to your people because Jack plays records for us. Yes. Because his bedroom's right off the kitchen, he cranks it.
Limited edition on vinyl. Oh, can I get one of those? Because we play records on Christmas morning. Yeah. Let me talk to my people. Talk to your people because Jack plays records for us. Yes. Because his bedroom's right off the kitchen, he cranks it.|||黑胶限量版。哦，我能弄到一张吗？因为我们会在圣诞节早晨放唱片。好的。我去跟我的团队说说。跟你的团队说说，因为杰克会为我们放唱片。是的。因为他的卧室紧挨着厨房，他会把声音开得很大。
We'll make it happen. And maybe if he becomes a DJ, he can, Looka, wika, wika, wika. Well, for me, getting ready for the holidays is putting up the tree. That's when I feel like things have started and I feel festive. But my hot tip is you don't have to do it all in the same day. Because for us, we have a faky tree, okay? And it's out in the shed.
We'll make it happen. And maybe if he becomes a DJ, he can, Looka, wika, wika, wika. Well, for me, getting ready for the holidays is putting up the tree. That's when I feel like things have started and I feel festive. But my hot tip is you don't have to do it all in the same day. Because for us, we have a faky tree, okay? And it's out in the shed.|||我们会实现的。也许如果他成为一名 DJ，他可以，“啦卡，维卡，维卡，维卡”。好吧，对我来说，为节日做准备就是摆起圣诞树。那是我觉得一切都开始了、有了节日气氛的时候。但我的实用小建议是：你不需要在同一天把所有事情都做完。因为对我们来说，我们有一棵假树，好吗？它放在杂物棚里。
And that means we've got to dig it out and dig out all the ornaments and all my throw pillows. I love a festive throw pillow. Just give it to me. I mean, you're saying that is if you don't also love a festive throw I wrote blanket. Exactly. I have Christmas blankets spitting. Anyway, so you dig it. Where does it end, Angela? Where does? This is an intervention. I know. I have my Christmas. I'm here. I have my Christmas village. I get very excited about. I love your village. It's so cute. And the kids help me. It does. And the kids set it all out. But anyway, what I've learned is that if we try to do it all in one day, someone has a meltdown. Always, always. And it's usually Josh. Because he's the one that's to dig everything out. So he's like, like, let's just get it all out. I'll get the tree up. And then we're done. And then we decorate the next day. So that's how we do it. That sounds very sensible. Yeah. And usually Christmas is not very sensible for most people. You feel like a child and you have to do it the way your mother did
And that means we've got to dig it out and dig out all the ornaments and all my throw pillows. I love a festive throw pillow. Just give it to me. I mean, you're saying that is if you don't also love a festive throw I wrote blanket. Exactly. I have Christmas blankets spitting. Anyway, so you dig it. Where does it end, Angela? Where does? This is an intervention. I know. I have my Christmas. I'm here. I have my Christmas village. I get very excited about. I love your village. It's so cute. And the kids help me. It does. And the kids set it all out. But anyway, what I've learned is that if we try to do it all in one day, someone has a meltdown. Always, always. And it's usually Josh. Because he's the one that's to dig everything out. So he's like, like, let's just get it all out. I'll get the tree up. And then we're done. And then we decorate the next day. So that's how we do it. That sounds very sensible. Yeah. And usually Christmas is not very sensible for most people. You feel like a child and you have to do it the way your mother did|||这意味着我们得把它挖出来，还要找出所有的装饰品和我所有的靠垫。我太喜欢节日靠垫了。快给我吧。我的意思是，你这么说，就好像你也很喜欢节日靠……我写了毯子。没错。我有无数的圣诞毯子。不管怎样，你把它挖出来。什么时候是个头啊，安吉拉？什么时候……这是一次干预。我知道。我有我的圣诞村。我在这里。我有我的圣诞村庄。我对此感到非常兴奋。我喜欢你的村庄。太可爱了。孩子们会帮我。确实如此。孩子们把它们全都摆好。不管怎样，我学到的是，如果我们试图在一天之内把所有事情都做完，就会有人崩溃。总是这样，总是这样。而且通常是乔许。因为他是那个得把所有东西都挖出来的人。所以他会说，就像是，我们把东西都弄出来吧。我把树搭好。然后我们就搞定。接着我们在第二天装饰。所以我们就是这么做的听起来很明智。是的。而且对大多数人来说，圣诞节通常不是那么明智的。你会觉得自己像个孩子，必须按照你母亲过去的方式去做
somewhere. That's so true, right? I live and grew up in a household where we only got the tree a couple days before because we always had a real tree. So if you get it too early, it's, you know, then you can't leave it up until the end of January. I know. Exactly. Yeah. It's true. But that's such a good point, like managing the traditions that you grew up with versus the traditions that actually work for your life. Yeah. Like, it wouldn't work for you to wait. No, I get home too late. Exactly.
somewhere. That's so true, right? I live and grew up in a household where we only got the tree a couple days before because we always had a real tree. So if you get it too early, it's, you know, then you can't leave it up until the end of January. I know. Exactly. Yeah. It's true. But that's such a good point, like managing the traditions that you grew up with versus the traditions that actually work for your life. Yeah. Like, it wouldn't work for you to wait. No, I get home too late. Exactly.|||在某些地方。太对了，对吧？我生活的家庭里，我们总是只在生日前几天才把树买回来，因为我们一直用真树。所以如果你买得太早，你知道的，你就没办法一直摆到一月底。我知道。确实。是的。这话说得太对了，比如如何处理你从小到大长大的传统，与那些真正适合你生活的传统之间的关系。是的。比如，对你来说，等待是行不通的。不，我回家太晚了。没错。
I usually fly to Philadelphia. I've seen my family. You know, yeah, yeah, I'm like, I'm all over the place. It's crazy. But I love the fact that you're figuring out the sanity. Whatever you need to do. Whatever you need to do. This, when you put your tree up is a hot debate online.
I usually fly to Philadelphia. I've seen my family. You know, yeah, yeah, I'm like, I'm all over the place. It's crazy. But I love the fact that you're figuring out the sanity. Whatever you need to do. Whatever you need to do. This, when you put your tree up is a hot debate online.|||我通常飞往费城。我已经见过家人了。你知道，对，对，我就是到处飞。太疯狂了。但我喜欢你一直在寻找理智的做法。无论你需要做什么。无论你需要做什么。这个，关于你什么时候摆圣诞树，是网上的一个热门争论话题。
I don't know if you know this. People get real, like, strong opinions about it. and I read a survey in good housekeeping. Do you want to know what I said? Yeah, please. Okay, most folks put up their tree at some point between December 2nd and December 23rd. But they also found that a common theme is that one and four people say they put up their tree on December 1st. But they did note that putting up a Christmas tree and decorating it is becoming an earlier and earlier tradition.
I don't know if you know this. People get real, like, strong opinions about it. and I read a survey in good housekeeping. Do you want to know what I said? Yeah, please. Okay, most folks put up their tree at some point between December 2nd and December 23rd. But they also found that a common theme is that one and four people say they put up their tree on December 1st. But they did note that putting up a Christmas tree and decorating it is becoming an earlier and earlier tradition.|||我不知道你知不知道这一点。人们对此有非常强烈的看法。我读了《美好家园》杂志上的一项调查。你想知道上面写了什么吗？好的，请说。好吧，大多数人在12月2日至12月23日之间的某个时间摆放他们的圣诞树。但他们还发现一个共同的主题是，四分之一的人表示他们在12月1日就摆好了树。不过他们确实指出，摆放圣诞树和进行装饰正变得越来越成为一种更早开始的传统。
I know people who put their trees up before Thanksgiving. You know, my mom has to put up her. tree before Thanksgiving because when we go home to visit, we visit on Thanksgiving. We don't visit on Christmas, but we celebrate Christmas. We do a thanksmas. One day is Thanksgiving. One day is Christmas. See, I'm fascinated by this. Yes. Yes. So she puts up all her Christmas decorations in time for Thanksgiving so that we can go and open gifts in a festive manner. Oh, I like that. I know some people that never take down their lights ever all year round. And that's okay. And that's Is it? I don't know. Is it? Okay. Here's my, wait, I saw something. I saw like a meme online or something
I know people who put their trees up before Thanksgiving. You know, my mom has to put up her. tree before Thanksgiving because when we go home to visit, we visit on Thanksgiving. We don't visit on Christmas, but we celebrate Christmas. We do a thanksmas. One day is Thanksgiving. One day is Christmas. See, I'm fascinated by this. Yes. Yes. So she puts up all her Christmas decorations in time for Thanksgiving so that we can go and open gifts in a festive manner. Oh, I like that. I know some people that never take down their lights ever all year round. And that's okay. And that's Is it? I don't know. Is it? Okay. Here's my, wait, I saw something. I saw like a meme online or something|||我认识一些在感恩节前就把圣诞树摆好的人。你知道，我妈妈必须在感恩节前把她的树摆好，因为当我们回家探亲时，我们在感恩节探亲。我们不在圣诞节探亲，但我们庆祝圣诞节。我们过感恩圣诞节（Thanksmas）。一天是感恩节。一天是圣诞节。看，我对这个很着迷。对的。对的。所以她在感恩节前摆好了她所有的圣诞装饰品，这样我们就可以去以节日的方式打开礼物。哦，我喜欢这样。我认识一些人，他们一年到头从不拆下灯饰。这也没关系。这也是……是吗？我不知道。是吗？好吧。这是我的，等等，我看到了什么。我在网上看到了一个梗或者别的什么
that was like the great thing about November. Oh my God, am I going to, I'm butchering it. But they were like, the great thing about November is you see the, forget it. You see the transition. Don't give up. Oh my God. Okay. You got this. It was like, it was like something like the great thing about November is you see all the people in your neighborhood who have left up their Halloween decorations. And then all the people who already have Christmas up, and you can see very clearly who's type A and type B in your neighborhood. And you can make a note for later. That is very funny.
that was like the great thing about November. Oh my God, am I going to, I'm butchering it. But they were like, the great thing about November is you see the, forget it. You see the transition. Don't give up. Oh my God. Okay. You got this. It was like, it was like something like the great thing about November is you see all the people in your neighborhood who have left up their Halloween decorations. And then all the people who already have Christmas up, and you can see very clearly who's type A and type B in your neighborhood. And you can make a note for later. That is very funny.|||类似于11月最棒的事。哦天哪，我是不是要……我把它说得一团糟。但他们是这样说的，11月最棒的事是你可以看到……算了吧。你可以看到过渡期。不要放弃。哦天哪。好吧。你能行的。就像是，11月最棒的事在于，你能看到你社区里所有还留着万圣节装饰的人。然后还有所有已经把圣诞装饰摆好的人，你能非常清楚地看出你邻居里谁是A型血（急性子）谁是B型血（慢性子）。你还可以记下来以后观察。这太搞笑了。
That's hilarious. I do judge if it's like mid-November and you have a few skeletons in the front yard, I'm like, get it together. Exactly. My brief six months living in Brooklyn, they would literally be cobwebs on the pilgrims on people's lawns, which I was like, oh, wow, you actually got pilgrims for Thanksgiving, which I thought was ambitious. But they kind of doubled up on Halloween and Thanksgiving at the same time, which I don't
That's hilarious. I do judge if it's like mid-November and you have a few skeletons in the front yard, I'm like, get it together. Exactly. My brief six months living in Brooklyn, they would literally be cobwebs on the pilgrims on people's lawns, which I was like, oh, wow, you actually got pilgrims for Thanksgiving, which I thought was ambitious. But they kind of doubled up on Halloween and Thanksgiving at the same time, which I don't|||太爆笑了。如果到了十一月中旬，你的前院里还挂着几个骷髅头，我确实会评头论足，心想：振作点吧。确实如此。我在布鲁克林短暂居住的六个月里，人们的草坪上居然会有挂在清教徒身上的蜘蛛网，当时我就想：哦，哇，你们居然为了感恩节准备了清教徒，我觉得这挺有野心的。但他们算是把万圣节和感恩节同时混在一起了，我不知道……
You know, I mean, it's interesting. It's an interesting part of the brain that I don't have. Zombie Pilgrims. I don't want to tell people what to do, but I started decorating a good amount of my Halloween decorations are just sort of like pumpkins and fall. And then I sprinkle in a few skeletons. And then when you take the skeletons away, boom. I already do the same thing.
You know, I mean, it's interesting. It's an interesting part of the brain that I don't have. Zombie Pilgrims. I don't want to tell people what to do, but I started decorating a good amount of my Halloween decorations are just sort of like pumpkins and fall. And then I sprinkle in a few skeletons. And then when you take the skeletons away, boom. I already do the same thing.|||你知道，我的意思是，这很有趣。这是我大脑中没有的一个有趣部分。僵尸清教徒。我不想指挥别人该做什么，但我开始装饰时，我的万圣节装饰里有相当一部分其实就是南瓜和秋天的元素。然后我点缀几个骷髅头。接着当你把骷髅头拿走时，砰。我也做过同样的事。
I do the same thing. Yeah. I think that's the. It's like a double decorating. It's a double deck. Yeah. Okay, wait. Multitasking.
I do the same thing. Yeah. I think that's the. It's like a double decorating. It's a double deck. Yeah. Okay, wait. Multitasking.|||我也做同样的事。是的。我觉得那是……这就像是双重装饰。这是一层加双层。是的。好吧，等等。多任务处理。
One last. One last tidbit from good housekeeping, because I thought this was interesting. So, you know, in ye olden times, like way, way back, ye olden times, Christmas decorations wouldn't be put up until the last possible moment because people decorated their trees with edible items like gingerbread, chocolates, other sweets. They were all hung on the branches with ribbon. And that continued into the Victorian times. Most people didn't put up their tree until, like, Christmas Eve to preserve the trees.
One last. One last tidbit from good housekeeping, because I thought this was interesting. So, you know, in ye olden times, like way, way back, ye olden times, Christmas decorations wouldn't be put up until the last possible moment because people decorated their trees with edible items like gingerbread, chocolates, other sweets. They were all hung on the branches with ribbon. And that continued into the Victorian times. Most people didn't put up their tree until, like, Christmas Eve to preserve the trees.|||最后一个。来自《美好家园》的最后一个趣闻，因为我觉得这个很有意思。所以，你知道，在过去的旧时光里，很久很久以前的旧时光，圣诞装饰直到最后一刻才会被挂起来，因为人们用可食用的物品装饰圣诞树，比如姜饼、巧克力和其他糖果。它们都是用丝带挂在树枝上的。这种情况一直延续到维多利亚时代。大多数人直到平安夜左右才把树摆起来，以便保存树木。
Totally. And actually, in my family, I remember. My parents, when they first got married, they used to do that. And then when my, I'm one of seven kids, so my oldest sister is like, you know, 13 and a half years older than me. So when they were little, they would go to sleep Christmas Eve with no tree and then wake up and it was like, what? So it was like Santa brought the tree.
Totally. And actually, in my family, I remember. My parents, when they first got married, they used to do that. And then when my, I'm one of seven kids, so my oldest sister is like, you know, 13 and a half years older than me. So when they were little, they would go to sleep Christmas Eve with no tree and then wake up and it was like, what? So it was like Santa brought the tree.|||完全是这样。事实上，在我家里，我记得。我父母刚结婚时，他们曾经那样做过。然后当我的……我是七个孩子中的一个，所以我大姐比我大十三岁半左右。所以当他们小的时候，他们会在没有圣诞树的情况下在平安夜入睡，然后醒来时发现，啊？就像是圣诞老人把树带来了。
That's what I was going to say. Wasn't there a thing for a while where Santa brought the tree? Could you imagine as a parent? Oh, my gosh. In addition to everything else, you have to decorate, you're putting together like a whole tree up with food on it? Yeah, while you're assembling a dollhouse and, you know, waiting, but, I mean, you got to wait for Santa for the rest of it. But boy, you really got to, you got to have Santa's cookies, you gotta do it, right?
That's what I was going to say. Wasn't there a thing for a while where Santa brought the tree? Could you imagine as a parent? Oh, my gosh. In addition to everything else, you have to decorate, you're putting together like a whole tree up with food on it? Yeah, while you're assembling a dollhouse and, you know, waiting, but, I mean, you got to wait for Santa for the rest of it. But boy, you really got to, you got to have Santa's cookies, you gotta do it, right?|||我正要这么说呢。有一段时间是不是流行过圣诞老人送树的说法？作为父母，你能想象吗？哦，天哪。除了其他所有你必须装饰的事情外，你还要把一整棵上面挂满食物的树拼起来？对啊，当你在组装一个娃娃屋，你知道的，还在等待，但是，我的意思是，其他部分你得等圣诞老人。但是天哪，你真的必须，你必须准备好圣诞老人的饼干，你得这么做，对吧？
Wow. It's, yeah, another reason to drink, you guys. You'll always find a reason. Meredith is here. You know, my dad had a bar, so, you know, the apple doesn't fall far from the alcoholic tree. This is not true about you in real life. You're like one of the most sensible people. You know, if I get invited, I'm usually.
Wow. It's, yeah, another reason to drink, you guys. You'll always find a reason. Meredith is here. You know, my dad had a bar, so, you know, the apple doesn't fall far from the alcoholic tree. This is not true about you in real life. You're like one of the most sensible people. You know, if I get invited, I'm usually.|||哇。这，是的，又多了一个喝酒的理由，伙计们。你们总能找到理由。梅雷迪思来了。你知道，我爸爸以前开过酒吧，所以，你知道的，有其父必有其子（酗酒的苹果离不开酒鬼树）。你在现实生活中可不是这样。你简直是最理智的人之一。你知道的，如果我被邀请，我通常会……
You are fun, but incredibly responsible. But I do have to ask you, Jenna, because I know you guys have traditions in St. Louis, and now I've learned about thanks Christmas. Is that how you say it? Thanks, Miss. It's so easy. You're saying you've learned about it. I've told you about thanksmas a million times.
You are fun, but incredibly responsible. But I do have to ask you, Jenna, because I know you guys have traditions in St. Louis, and now I've learned about thanks Christmas. Is that how you say it? Thanks, Miss. It's so easy. You're saying you've learned about it. I've told you about thanksmas a million times.|||你很有趣，但极其负责任。不过我不得不问你，珍娜，因为我知道你们在圣路易斯有传统，现在我了解了“感恩圣诞节”（thanks Christmas）。你是这么叫的吗？Thanks, Miss（感恩节小姐）。这太简单了。你说你了解了。我已经跟你说过一百万次 Thanksmas 了。
No, no, no, no. I know the tradition. I didn't know you called it thanksmas. I've talked about it on the podcast before. You've never called it thanksmas. I have. It's okay. Does she really?
No, no, no, no. I know the tradition. I didn't know you called it thanksmas. I've talked about it on the podcast before. You've never called it thanksmas. I have. It's okay. Does she really?|||不，不，不，不。我知道这个传统。我不知道你管它叫 Thanksmas。我以前在播客里谈过它。你从来没叫过它 Thanksmas。我叫过。没关系。她真的叫过吗？
It's okay. I don't know. It didn't stick with me. Clearly. You know what? Clearly did not. Keep more interesting. No kidding. Let me. Let me pivot. I have to pivot differently. Don't pivot. This is staying in. This is an insight into my friendship with Angela. You stop it. I'm going to stop it. I blame myself. No, no, no. I do. I do. Oh, my God. Angela, you, of course, you're the most thoughtful and wonderful friend. You just forgot that I called it. Thanks, Miss, even though I've been calling it that. for 20 years. Fine. Don't worry about it. Let it go. We're letting it go. Okay. I prefer Chris giving, but is that just me? I think we need to take a survey. I think we need to ask everybody.
It's okay. I don't know. It didn't stick with me. Clearly. You know what? Clearly did not. Keep more interesting. No kidding. Let me. Let me pivot. I have to pivot differently. Don't pivot. This is staying in. This is an insight into my friendship with Angela. You stop it. I'm going to stop it. I blame myself. No, no, no. I do. I do. Oh, my God. Angela, you, of course, you're the most thoughtful and wonderful friend. You just forgot that I called it. Thanks, Miss, even though I've been calling it that. for 20 years. Fine. Don't worry about it. Let it go. We're letting it go. Okay. I prefer Chris giving, but is that just me? I think we need to take a survey. I think we need to ask everybody.|||没关系。我不知道。我没记住。很显然。你知道吗？显然没有。保持更有趣。不开玩笑。让我……让我转换一下话题。我得换个方式转换。别转话题。这段要保留。这是深入了解我和安吉拉友谊的一个窗口。你别闹了。我要停下来了。我怪我自己。不，不，不。我怪。我怪。哦，天哪。安吉拉，你，当然了，你是最体贴、最棒的朋友。你只是忘了我管它叫 Thanks, Miss，尽管我这么叫了20年。好吧。别担心。算了吧。我们不提了。好吧。我更喜欢“克里斯节”（Chris giving），难道只有我一个人这样觉得吗？我觉得我们需要做个调查。我觉得我们需要问问每个人。
I can pivot to Chris giving. Chris giving. Well, that sounds like, it sounds like there's a guy named Chris who's giving me stuff. Pretty generous. Now, Chris giving, I'll remember. No, I'm kidding. Okay. So what are some other traditions, Jenna, that you do to prep for the holidays? Well, my big prep for the holidays, I shop early. Now, I know this about you. I'm so jealous. When I say early, my mom, Ann Fisher, she starts shopping in July.
I can pivot to Chris giving. Chris giving. Well, that sounds like, it sounds like there's a guy named Chris who's giving me stuff. Pretty generous. Now, Chris giving, I'll remember. No, I'm kidding. Okay. So what are some other traditions, Jenna, that you do to prep for the holidays? Well, my big prep for the holidays, I shop early. Now, I know this about you. I'm so jealous. When I say early, my mom, Ann Fisher, she starts shopping in July.|||我可以转到“克里斯节”。Chris giving。嗯，听起来像是一个叫克里斯的家伙在送我东西。挺大方的。现在，“克里斯节”，我能记住。不，我开玩笑呢。好的。珍娜，为了准备节日，你还有哪些别的传统？嗯，我为节日做的最大准备是，我买东西很早。这个我知道。我太嫉妒了。当我说是“早”的时候，我妈妈安·费舍尔，她在七月份就开始购物了。
Wow. And this was, oh, yeah, because she would do a lot of shopping at the Lake of the Ozark outlet malls, which is now gone. But she would always be, like, she'll find little, like, treasures in the summer, and she squirrels them away in her closet. Does she forget about any of them? Yes. Okay. Very often she'll find something in like March when she's doing spring cleaning and then she'll stick it in the mail.
Wow. And this was, oh, yeah, because she would do a lot of shopping at the Lake of the Ozark outlet malls, which is now gone. But she would always be, like, she'll find little, like, treasures in the summer, and she squirrels them away in her closet. Does she forget about any of them? Yes. Okay. Very often she'll find something in like March when she's doing spring cleaning and then she'll stick it in the mail.|||哇。而且这是……哦，对，因为她会在欧扎克湖奥特莱斯购物中心买很多东西，现在那个地方已经没了。但她总是，比如，她会在夏天找到一些小“宝藏”，然后把它们藏在衣柜里。她会忘记其中的一些吗？会的。好吧。很多时候，她会在三月份大扫除时发现某样东西，然后把它寄到邮件里。
She'll be like, I'm so sorry. I forgot I bought you the scarf. It was a Christmas present. I'm glad she's not a hoarder and I'm glad she didn't keep it because maybe unconsciously she just wanted more stuff for herself. But that's clearly not the case. Good for her. This has rubbed off on me.
She'll be like, I'm so sorry. I forgot I bought you the scarf. It was a Christmas present. I'm glad she's not a hoarder and I'm glad she didn't keep it because maybe unconsciously she just wanted more stuff for herself. But that's clearly not the case. Good for her. This has rubbed off on me.|||她会说：太对不起了。我忘了我给你买过这条围巾。这是圣诞礼物。我很高兴她不是个囤积狂，也很高兴她没有把东西留下，因为也许在潜意识里她只是想要更多的东西留给自己。但显然情况并非如此。真为她高兴。这也对我产生了影响。
And I actually, I find like the Black Friday shopping after Thanksgiving. If I wait that long to get the bulk of my gifts, I feel stressed out. I don't like that. I kind of actually like to shop and get almost all of my shopping done in October and November. You guys, I'm a Christmas Eve shopper. I really am sometimes. I know, I know. You're at the mall just in person.
And I actually, I find like the Black Friday shopping after Thanksgiving. If I wait that long to get the bulk of my gifts, I feel stressed out. I don't like that. I kind of actually like to shop and get almost all of my shopping done in October and November. You guys, I'm a Christmas Eve shopper. I really am sometimes. I know, I know. You're at the mall just in person.|||实际上，我发现感恩节后的黑色星期五购物……如果我等到那个时候才去买大部分礼物，我会感到压力山大。我不喜欢那样。我其实更喜欢在十月和十一月把几乎所有的购物都买完。伙计们，我是个平安夜购物狂。有时我真的是这样。我知道，我知道。你本人就在商场里。
I feel like ever since high school, I would go into the city in Philadelphia from the burbs and like, you know, deal with all the, there's only one box left. And someone like screaming at someone else in line. Do you like the chaos? Maybe you like throwing some elbows. I didn't think I did. I don't know. I'm just addicted to trouble. I don't know. I don't know. It's bad. I want that on a pillow for you. Well, ladies, I feel like we've covered Cindy's question. Should we go to Maggie M. in Maryland? She sent us a really fun Meredith question. Okay. Hi, office ladies. I love it when you break down fan theories. And I was wondering if you could discuss whether Meredith represents Pam's future if she had married Roy instead of Jim.
I feel like ever since high school, I would go into the city in Philadelphia from the burbs and like, you know, deal with all the, there's only one box left. And someone like screaming at someone else in line. Do you like the chaos? Maybe you like throwing some elbows. I didn't think I did. I don't know. I'm just addicted to trouble. I don't know. It's bad. I want that on a pillow for you. Well, ladies, I feel like we've covered Cindy's question. Should we go to Maggie M. in Maryland? She sent us a really fun Meredith question. Okay. Hi, office ladies. I love it when you break down fan theories. And I was wondering if you could discuss whether Meredith represents Pam's future if she had married Roy instead of Jim.|||我觉得自从高中以来，我就会从郊区进到费城市中心，然后，你知道的，去应付那些……只剩最后一个盒子了。还有人在排队时对别人尖叫。你喜欢这种混乱吗？也许你喜欢肘击别人。我以前不觉得自己喜欢。我不知道。我只是对麻烦上瘾。我不知道。这太糟糕了。我想把这句话印在枕头上送给你。好吧，女士们，我觉得我们已经回答了辛迪的问题。我们要不要去看看马里兰州的玛吉·M？她给我们发了一个非常有趣的关于梅雷迪思的问题。好的。嗨，办公室女士。我非常喜欢你们剖析粉丝理论。我想知道你们能不能讨论一下，梅雷迪思是否代表了潘如果嫁给罗伊而不是吉姆之后的未来。
Thank you. Have you heard this fan theory? I have not, but I kind of love it. It's sort of amazing, right? And don't you feel like the whole ICE episode was a little bit of a glimpse into Pam's life if she didn't have a supportive husband at home? Because Jim was away.
Thank you. Have you heard this fan theory? I have not, but I kind of love it. It's sort of amazing, right? And don't you feel like the whole ICE episode was a little bit of a glimpse into Pam's life if she didn't have a supportive husband at home? Because Jim was away.|||谢谢。你们听说过这个粉丝理论吗？我没听说过，但我有点喜欢。这有点神奇，对吧？而且你不觉得整个冰上嘉年华（ICE）那一集就像是窥见了潘如果家里没有一个支持她的丈夫的生活吗？因为吉姆当时不在。
And you know, Roy would have been totally absent, I think. He would have been on his wave runners. Exactly. with his brother. And her and Meredith really bond. This is true. There's nothing like a little girls just want to have fun karaoke. I know. Kate, I just recently came across a ton of pictures of of you from that episode. Do you know that you went around to every single cast member and took a picture with them? I remember. Yeah. Oh my gosh. I actually have them on my computer. I'm sure some of them were like, it's okay. I don't need my picture with you today. I mean, they are amazing. I want, here's like,
And you know, Roy would have been totally absent, I think. He would have been on his wave runners. Exactly. with his brother. And her and Meredith really bond. This is true. There's nothing like a little girls just want to have fun karaoke. I know. Kate, I just recently came across a ton of pictures of of you from that episode. Do you know that you went around to every single cast member and took a picture with them? I remember. Yeah. Oh my gosh. I actually have them on my computer. I'm sure some of them were like, it's okay. I don't need my picture with you today. I mean, they are amazing. I want, here's like,|||你知道的，我觉得罗伊会完全不管事。他会去玩他的水上摩托。没错。和他兄弟一起。她和梅雷迪思真的建立起了深厚的感情。这是真的。没有什么比唱一首《女孩只想寻开心》卡拉OK更好的了。我知道。凯特，我最近偶然看到了大量你在那一集的照片。你知道吗，你绕着每一位演员都跟他们合了影？我记得。是的。哦，天哪。我其实把它们存在电脑里了。我敢肯定其中有些人会觉得：没关系，我今天不需要跟你合影。我的意思是，它们太棒了。我想……这里有一个，比如，
one of my favorites, though, and you'll have to tell us if Chris took this, it's just you playing solitaire, but you have no hair. He might have, yeah. You guys, I don't know if you know, my boyfriend, Chris Hasten, was the photographer on the office, and he was the chief stills guy at NBC for years. He shot a ton of shows, Seinfeld and friends, everything, everything, even the Golden Girls. Look at this one in the conference room. Oh, my God, hilarious. Look at your face. You're like cracking yourself up. I mean, every time I see that bald cap work, it is just masterful. Yeah, I can't believe it. It was crazy.
one of my favorites, though, and you'll have to tell us if Chris took this, it's just you playing solitaire, but you have no hair. He might have, yeah. You guys, I don't know if you know, my boyfriend, Chris Hasten, was the photographer on the office, and he was the chief stills guy at NBC for years. He shot a ton of shows, Seinfeld and friends, everything, everything, even the Golden Girls. Look at this one in the conference room. Oh, my God, hilarious. Look at your face. You're like cracking yourself up. I mean, every time I see that bald cap work, it is just masterful. Yeah, I can't believe it. It was crazy.|||其中一张是我的最爱，你得告诉我们这盘是不是克里斯拍的，那是你正在玩纸牌接龙，但你没有头发。他可能拍过，对的。伙计们，我不知道你们知不知道，我的男友克里斯·海斯滕曾是《办公室》的摄影师，他多年来一直是 NBC 的首席剧照师。他拍过大量节目，比如《宋飞正传》和《老友记》，什么都拍，甚至还拍过《黄金女郎》。看看会议室里的这一张。哦，天哪，太搞笑了。看看你的脸。你简直把自己逗笑了。我的意思是，每次看到那个光头头套的作品，都觉得太大师级了。是的，我简直不敢相信。太疯狂了。
And the artist that did it, his name is Ed French. He teaches other makeup artists how to do the bald cap because he did the blood vessels. He did like the stubble. Look, he did little tiny moles because we all have moles on our scalp. Yeah. Like the work he did was amazing. Yeah, he's really incredible. I mean, he's done famous, like there's a Star Trek movie from 1980 where there's a bald woman in it.
And the artist that did it, his name is Ed French. He teaches other makeup artists how to do the bald cap because he did the blood vessels. He did like the stubble. Look, he did little tiny moles because we all have moles on our scalp. Yeah. Like the work he did was amazing. Yeah, he's really incredible. I mean, he's done famous, like there's a Star Trek movie from 1980 where there's a bald woman in it.|||做这个的化妆师名叫埃德·弗伦奇。他教其他化妆师如何制作光头头套，因为他做出了血管的效果。他还做出了胡茬。看，他做了很小的痣，因为我们头皮上都有痣。是的。他做的工作太棒了。是的，他真的很不可思议。我的意思是，他做过很有名的作品，比如1980年有一部《星际迷航》电影，里面有个光头女人。
I can't remember her character's name, but she's on the poster and he did that bald cap. Wow. Yeah, Ed French. He's unbelievable. So, yeah, it was worth the four and a half hours every morning to get into that. Four and a half hours, Kate? And then it took, like, almost three to get out of it. Stop. I didn't realize you were in there. I've new respect for all my sci-fi actor friends.
I can't remember her character's name, but she's on the poster and he did that bald cap. Wow. Yeah, Ed French. He's unbelievable. So, yeah, it was worth the four and a half hours every morning to get into that. Four and a half hours, Kate? And then it took, like, almost three to get out of it. Stop. I didn't realize you were in there. I've new respect for all my sci-fi actor friends.|||我记不得她角色的名字了，但她在海报上，那个光头头套就是他做的。哇。是的，埃德·弗伦奇。他太令人难以置信了。所以，是的，每天早上花四个半小时化这个妆是值得的。四个半小时，凯特？然后卸妆还要花将近三个小时。别说了。我不知道你在里面待了那么久。我对所有科幻片演员朋友有了新的敬意。
I have weird makeup every day. So what was your call time then? I never left. I just would sleep. I mean, kind of true. Where you're just like, can I just wear it home at this point? I guess to God, I know it would have been faster. I think it was literally like 345, like 3.35, like it was early or four. Wow.
I have weird makeup every day. So what was your call time then? I never left. I just would sleep. I mean, kind of true. Where you're just like, can I just wear it home at this point? I guess to God, I know it would have been faster. I think it was literally like 345, like 3.35, like it was early or four. Wow.|||我每天都要化奇怪的妆。那你当时的集合时间是什么时候？我从来没离开过。我直接就在那儿睡觉。我的意思是，差不多是真的。你当时就会想：在这个时候我能直接戴着它回家吗？上帝啊，我知道那样会更快。我想当时大概是3点45，或者3点35，反正很早，差不多四点。哇。
Yeah, it was early. Yeah, it was really. But, you know, I mean, it was worth it. I didn't want to shave my head for real, so. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. That's all right. Well, how about this, ladies? Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to talk about our favorite, the office holiday memories. I like this idea. Okay. Okay. We are back with Kate. And I'm... I want to chat now about the office holiday memories. Kate, what office holiday moment do you hear about most from fans that has to do with your character on the holidays? Is there a quote? Is there a scene? Well, in the first Christmas episode, there's two. But the first is
Yeah, it was early. Yeah, it was really. But, you know, I mean, it was worth it. I didn't want to shave my head for real, so. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. That's all right. Well, how about this, ladies? Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to talk about our favorite, the office holiday memories. I like this idea. Okay. Okay. We are back with Kate. And I'm... I want to chat now about the office holiday memories. Kate, what office holiday moment do you hear about most from fans that has to do with your character on the holidays? Is there a quote? Is there a scene? Well, in the first Christmas episode, there's two. But the first is|||是的，真的很早。是的，确实如此。但是，你知道的，我的意思是，这一切都是值得的。我可不想真的把头剃光，所以……是的。哦，天哪。没关系。好吧，女士们，这样如何？我们休息一下怎么样？等我们回来后，我们要聊聊我们最喜欢的《办公室》节日回忆。我喜欢这个主意。好的。好的。我们和凯特回来了。我……我现在想聊聊《办公室》的节日回忆。凯特，关于你的角色在节日期间的表现，你从粉丝那里听到最多的《办公室》节日时刻是什么？是一句台词吗？还是一个场景？嗯，在第一集圣诞节剧集里，有两个。但第一个是
my talking head. And people always... They always quote it. Some of it was written and a little bit of it was improvised. And I was really happy that my improv part made it in. Oh, I think we should hear it. Let's hear it. Let's grab it. The deal is that this is my last hurrah because I made a New Year's resolution that I'm not going to drink anymore during the week.
my talking head. And people always... They always quote it. Some of it was written and a little bit of it was improvised. And I was really happy that my improv part made it in. Oh, I think we should hear it. Let's hear it. Let's grab it. The deal is that this is my last hurrah because I made a New Year's resolution that I'm not going to drink anymore during the week.|||我的单人采访（talking head）。人们总是……他们总是引用它。其中一部分是写好的台词，有一小部分是即兴发挥的。我真的很高兴我即兴发挥的部分被剪进去了。哦，我觉得我们应该听听。我们听听看。把它放出来。情况是这样的，这是我的最后狂欢，因为我许下了一个新年愿望，那就是我一周内再也不喝酒了。
I just added the during the week. You added during the week? I did. Oh my gosh. Kate, that's the singer of it. That's the whole thing. Oh, it's brilliant. We have the best writers in TV, though.
I just added the during the week. You added during the week? I did. Oh my gosh. Kate, that's the singer of it. That's the whole thing. Oh, it's brilliant. We have the best writers in TV, though.|||我只是加了“一周内”这几个字。你加了“一周内”？我加的。哦，天哪。凯特，这才是点睛之笔。这才是精髓所在。哦，太棒了。不过，我们拥有电视界最好的编剧。
You have to understand. I always think of whenever I improvise on the show and it makes it on, I'm like, oh, because the writers literally tilled the soil. They teed you up, yeah. They laid a carpet. They put a brass band down the path before I got there. And I take two extra steps and that's what happens.
You have to understand. I always think of whenever I improvise on the show and it makes it on, I'm like, oh, because the writers literally tilled the soil. They teed you up, yeah. They laid a carpet. They put a brass band down the path before I got there. And I take two extra steps and that's what happens.|||你得明白。每当我在这部剧里即兴发挥并且被播出来时，我总是会想：哦……因为编剧们简直是把地都耕好了。他们给你做好了铺垫，是的。他们铺好了地毯。在我到那儿之前，他们就在路上安排好了铜管乐队。而我只是多走了两步，事情就成了这样。
It's so true, though, because we had such a great foundation. Yeah, they just set us up perfectly. So if anything you had in your mind that might work or take it to another level, it was like, it was a dream. It was a dream. So there's that line. And then, of course, the scene where Meredith walks in and takes her top off and Michael Scott takes a picture. That's the one I thought. Oh, my God.
It's so true, though, because we had such a great foundation. Yeah, they just set us up perfectly. So if anything you had in your mind that might work or take it to another level, it was like, it was a dream. It was a dream. So there's that line. And then, of course, the scene where Meredith walks in and takes her top off and Michael Scott takes a picture. That's the one I thought. Oh, my God.|||确实如此，因为我们有这么棒的基础。是的，他们把一切都为我们铺垫得完美无缺。所以，如果你脑子里有什么觉得行得通或者能把它提升到一个新高度的想法，那简直就像是一个梦。简直是个梦。所以台词就是这样。然后，当然就是梅雷迪思走进来脱掉上衣、迈克尔·斯科特拍照的那场戏。那就是我想的那一场。哦，天哪。
I thought I bet people. Yeah. I'm so happy to hear that in an airport, you guys. Thanks so much. Oh, no. What do they say? How do they, how do they like? Hey, remember when you took your top off in front of my.
I thought I bet people. Yeah. I'm so happy to hear that in an airport, you guys. Thanks so much. Oh, no. What do they say? How do they, how do they like? Hey, remember when you took your top off in front of my.|||我想我敢打赌人们……是的。听到这个消息我太开心了，在一个机场里，伙计们。非常感谢。哦，不。他们说什么？他们是怎么……他们是怎么说的？嘿，还记得你当年在我面前脱掉上衣的时候吗？
Oh, my gosh. Everybody lost in the airport, clearly, Logan. She's like, remember when you take your top off? Yeah. Hey. And my parents are so proud. Angela, what about you? Oh, man.
Oh, my gosh. Everyone lost in the airport, clearly, Logan. She's like, remember when you take your top off? Yeah. Hey. And my parents are so proud. Angela, what about you? Oh, man.|||哦，天哪。机场里的所有人都惊呆了，显然，洛根。她就像是：还记得你脱掉上衣的时候吗？是的。嘿。我的父母感到无比骄傲。安吉拉，你呢？哦，天哪。
I mean, my character had a bunch of Christmas-like moments because the party planning committee, right? So, I mean, we already talked about this, but when I throw the ornaments in the parking lot and smash them, people love that. The screech is like insane. You know, here's the thing. The screech was real because they were supposed to give me ornaments. that shatter, like ready to break, like breakable ornaments. And I don't know what happened, but they got the wrong ones, and those were plastic. So the first time I threw it on the ground with everything I had, expecting it to
I mean, my character had a bunch of Christmas-like moments because the party planning committee, right? So, I mean, we already talked about this, but when I throw the ornaments in the parking lot and smash them, people love that. The screech is like insane. You know, here's the thing. The screech was real because they were supposed to give me ornaments. that shatter, like ready to break, like breakable ornaments. And I don't know what happened, but they got the wrong ones, and those were plastic. So the first time I threw it on the ground with everything I had, expecting it to|||我的意思是，我的角色有很多类似圣诞的时刻，因为有派对策划委员会对吧？所以，我的意思是，我们已经聊过这个了，但当我把装饰品扔进停车场并砸碎它们时，人们超级喜欢那个。那个尖叫声简直疯狂。你知道，事情是这样的。那个尖叫声是真的，因为他们本来应该给我那种会碎的装饰品，就是一碰就碎、易碎的装饰品。我不知道发生了什么，他们拿错了，那些是塑料的。所以第一次我用尽全身力气把它扔在地上，以为它会……
shatter, it bounced right back up like a tennis ball. And so I couldn't break them. I physically couldn't break them. Is that why you stomp them? That's why I stomp them and shriek because I'm like, f***ing break. And there was a guy on the roof doing the snow. and Charles McDougal was like, are we going to get this shot or not?
shatter, it bounced right back up like a tennis ball. And so I couldn't break them. I physically couldn't break them. Is that why you stomp them? That's why I stomp them and shriek because I'm like, f***ing break. And there was a guy on the roof doing the snow. and Charles McDougal was like, are we going to get this shot or not?|||碎掉，结果它像网球一样直接弹了回来。所以我根本砸不碎它们。我用尽力气也砸不碎。这就是你踩碎它们的原因？这就是为什么我踩它们并尖叫，因为我在想：快给我碎啊。当时屋顶上还有一个负责搞人造雪的工作人员。查尔斯·麦克道格尔当时说：我们到底能不能拍到这个镜头？
Our director was so great. He was so great, but I knew if the ornaments didn't break, it wouldn't make it in. I really wanted that moment to make it in. Totally. And it was such a great moment. Oh my God, it's so, it's chilling.
Our director was so great. He was so great, but I knew if the ornaments didn't break, it wouldn't make it in. I really wanted that moment to make it in. Totally. And it was such a great moment. Oh my God, it's so, it's chilling.|||我们的导演太棒了。他太棒了，但我知道如果装饰品不碎，这个镜头就剪不进去。我真的非常想让那个时刻被剪进正片。完全是这样。而且那真是个太棒的时刻了。哦，天哪，太……让人毛骨悚然了。
It's like it's so, and it so leads to that Christmas frustration where it's like you end up being the opposite of what you want to be, which is like happy and merry and kind. It's like there's always, you know, I don't know, I feel like most people have one, especially if you're like a woman, you have a moment where you're like, ugh, why isn't this going working?
It's like it's so, and it so leads to that Christmas frustration where it's like you end up being the opposite of what you want to be, which is like happy and merry and kind. It's like there's always, you know, I don't know, I feel like most people have one, especially if you're like a woman, you have a moment where you're like, ugh, why isn't this going working?|||就好像是，它太……而且它完美契合了那种圣诞节的挫败感，你最后表现得和你想要成为的恰恰相反——你本想快乐、愉快、善良。就好像总会有……我不知道，我觉得大多数人都有过这样的时刻，尤其是作为一个女性，你总会有那么一刻觉得：呃，为什么这事儿就是不顺利？
Yeah. Yeah. So I think the fact that they bounced and then I had to step on them actually, like, played up the frustration. So good. And then I would say, I have two other ones. One is when my character sings Little Drummer Boy and then Dwight helps her out, that people love Little Drummer Boy, you guys. You just recreated it at the con. I did at the fan convention.
Yeah. Yeah. So I think the fact that they bounced and then I had to step on them actually, like, played up the frustration. So good. And then I would say, I have two other ones. One is when my character sings Little Drummer Boy and then Dwight helps her out, that people love Little Drummer Boy, you guys. You just recreated it at the con. I did at the fan convention.|||对的。对的。所以我觉得它们弹起来然后我不得不踩上去，实际上反而把那种挫败感表现得淋漓尽致。太棒了。然后我想说，我还有另外两个时刻。一个是我的角色唱《小鼓手男孩》，然后德怀特帮她搭腔，大家真的超爱《小鼓手男孩》，伙计们。你们刚刚在漫展上重现了这个。我在粉丝漫展上重现过。
Rain and I did that. And then the quote, people say, the first time someone said it to me, I had forgotten that my character said it. And I was like, what? But I literally had someone say this to me. I'm not going to judge Phyllis for desecrating Christmas. There is one person who will, though, and Phyllis just stuffed him into a drawer. And I was like, I was literally like at the mall. And I was like, what? Phyllis did who, huh? What? Oh my God. But yeah, that's when Phyllis is in charge of the party. And it's a rocking theme. And she shoves my nation. activity scene into my drawer. Oh, my God. Yes. So, yeah, okay, wait, Jenna, what about you? Well, I have one thing that comes back to me every holiday season, and it's this, you know that talking head, Pam, I think she's in the break room, and she says, if you use more than three
Rain and I did that. And then the quote, people say, the first time someone said it to me, I had forgotten that my character said it. And I was like, what? But I literally had someone say this to me. I'm not going to judge Phyllis for desecrating Christmas. There is one person who will, though, and Phyllis just stuffed him into a drawer. And I was like, I was literally like at the mall. And I was like, what? Phyllis did who, huh? What? Oh my God. But yeah, that's when Phyllis is in charge of the party. And it's a rocking theme. And she shoves my nation. activity scene into my drawer. Oh, my God. Yes. So, yeah, okay, wait, Jenna, what about you? Well, I have one thing that comes back to me every holiday season, and it's this, you know that talking head, Pam, I think she's in the break room, and she says, if you use more than three|||雷恩和我一起做的。然后是那句台词，人们说，当第一次有人对我说起时，我都忘了我的角色说过这句台词。当时我就想：什么？但真的有人对我这么说过。我不会评判菲利斯亵渎圣诞节的行为。不过有一个人会，而菲利斯直接把他塞进了一个抽屉里。当时我的反应是……我当时真的在商场里，然后我就想：什么？菲利斯把谁怎么了？哈？什么？哦，天哪。但是，是的，那是菲利斯负责派对的时候。那是一个摇滚主题。她把我的耶稣诞生场景塞进了我的抽屉里。哦，天哪。是的。所以，好吧，等等，珍娜，你呢？嗯，我有一件事每到节日季就会浮现在脑海里，就是这个，你知道潘的那个单人采访吗，我想她是在休息室里，她说，如果你用了超过三个
pieces of tape to wrap a gift, you're doing it wrong. Oh, wow. And people send me that. It haunts me. When I'm wrapping gifts, I think of this thing that Pam said. And I'm like, I guess I'm doing it wrong because I need more than three pieces of tape. It's ridiculous. Three pieces of tape?
pieces of tape to wrap a gift, you're doing it wrong. Oh, and people send me that. It haunts me. When I'm wrapping gifts, I think of this thing that Pam said. And I'm like, I guess I'm doing it wrong because I need more than three pieces of tape. It's ridiculous. Three pieces of tape?|||条胶带去包装礼物，那你就是包装错了。哦，天哪。人们经常把这个发给我。这简直成了我的挥之不去的阴影。当我包礼物时，我就会想起潘说的这句话。然后我心想：我猜我大概是做错了，因为我需要用到不止三条胶带。太荒谬了。三条胶带？
So it's like one on the one end, on the other end and one in the middle. That's it. That's all you're supposed to use. My dad could do it. Oh, wow. My dad, when he wraps a gift, he will line up the paper. He'll cut it so that it's like a seamless transition in the print. Wow.
So it's like one on the one end, on the other end and one in the middle. That's it. That's all you're supposed to use. My dad could do it. Oh, wow. My dad, when he wraps a gift, he will line up the paper. He'll cut it so that it's like a seamless transition in the print. Wow.|||所以就像一头粘一条，另一头粘一条，中间再粘一条。就这样。这就是你全部应该用的量。我爸爸就能做到。哦，哇。我爸爸在包礼物时，他会把对齐纸张。他会裁剪它，让图案的拼接处看起来天衣无缝。哇。
So that like the magician? What? He's an engineer. Oh. So that matters to him. He wraps all the gifts in the family. My mom buys all the gifts. My dad wraps all the gifts.
So that like the magician? What? He's an engineer. Oh. So that matters to him. He wraps all the gifts in the family. My mom buys all the gifts. My dad wraps all the gifts.|||所以就像魔术师一样？什么？他是个工程师。哦。所以这对很重要。他包揽了家里所有的礼物包装。我妈妈负责买所有的礼物。我爸爸负责包所有的礼物。
That's their partner. That's for Christmas. Literally. I know. My mom is a bow master, guys. Wow. Does she do the homemade bows? Homemade bows.
That's their partner. That's for Christmas. Literally. I know. My mom is a bow master, guys. Wow. Does she do the homemade bows? Homemade bows.|||这就是他们的搭档方式。这就是圣诞节的分工。真的。我知道。我妈妈是个蝴蝶结大师，伙计们。哇。她会自己做蝴蝶结吗？手工蝴蝶结。
Oh, wow. She does homemade bows, but she'll do like, she'll get like a red and black plaid bow to go on like the brown parchment so it pops. But then like she gave me one time. She got a little tiny red cardinal bird and made like a little nest and put the red cardinal in the nest on top of the bow. I don't even want to open it. It's so beautiful. Oh, well, your mom did homemade bows.
Oh, wow. She does homemade bows, but she'll do like, she'll get like a red and black plaid bow to go on like the brown parchment so it pops. But then like she gave me one time. She got a little tiny red cardinal bird and made like a little nest and put the red cardinal in the nest on top of the bow. I don't even want to open it. It's so beautiful. Oh, well, your mom did homemade bows.|||哦，哇。她会做手工蝴蝶结，但她会做那种……她会用红黑格子的蝴蝶结搭配棕色牛皮纸，让它显得很突出。但后来，有一次她送我……她弄了一只红色的微型红衣主教鸟，做了一个小鸟窝，然后把红衣主教放在蝴蝶结上方的鸟窝里。我都舍不得打开了。太美了。哦，好吧，你妈妈会做手工蝴蝶结。
My dad actually made homemade booze. We've so much a couple. Seriously. We made it through an amazing, amazing eggnog. Like it was lethal. Like a boozy eggnog? But he would make the actual eggnog with the eggs. Like he would do the whole thing.
My dad actually made homemade booze. We've so much a couple. Seriously. We made it through an amazing, amazing eggnog. Like it was lethal. Like a boozy eggnog? But he would make the actual eggnog with the eggs. Like he would do the whole thing.|||我爸爸其实会自己酿酒（homemade booze）。我们这对夫妻太有默契了。说真的。我们做过一款非常、非常棒的蛋酒（eggnog）。简直能把人喝倒。就像加了酒的蛋酒？但他会用真正的鸡蛋来做蛋酒。就像他会亲手完成整个过程。
And he would always give it to the nuns and the priests. And the meanest nuns would be like, oh, Oh, Mr. Flannery. All this is like, we're so happy to see you. We got your gift. I'm like, what did you give them? As a kid, I was like, what? She's got another personality?
And he would always give it to the nuns and the priests. And the meanest nuns would be like, oh, Mr. Flannery. All this is like, we're so happy to see you. We got your gift. I'm like, what did you give them? As a kid, I was like, what? She's got another personality?|||而且他总是把它送给修女和神父。最凶的修女也会说：哦，弗兰纳里先生。这一切都像是……见到你太高兴了。我们收到你的礼物了。我就想：你送了他们什么？小时候，我就觉得：什么？她还有另一重人格？
What's happening? What's in the eggnog, dad? But it's truly, truly magic. Yeah, totally. Well, listen, speaking of gift wrapping, I had to reach out to Kendra Adachi. You know her as the lazy genius because she has an amazing tradition for wrapping gifts at the holidays that lady I think you're going to like,
What's happening? What's in the eggnog, dad? But it's truly, truly magic. Yeah, totally. Well, listen, speaking of gift wrapping, I had to reach out to Kendra Adachi. You know her as the lazy genius because she has an amazing tradition for wrapping gifts at the holidays that lady I think you're going to like,|||这到底是怎么回事？蛋酒里放了什么，爸爸？但它真的是、真的是太神奇了。是的，完全如此。好吧，听着，说到包装礼物，我不得不联系肯德拉·安达奇（Kendra Adachi）。你们知道她是“懒人天才”（the lazy genius），因为她在节日包装礼物时有一个超赞的传统，那位女士，我觉得你会喜欢，
especially. Really? Yes. Okay, let's hear it. She sent in an audio clip explaining her holiday gift wrapping tradition. Hey, Jenna and Angela, it's Kendra from the Lazy Genius podcast. Okay, Angela, I heard that you might really like something that I do every Christmas season. So I love giving gifts and we have a large family and I wrap every stocking stuffer because maybe I'm crazy. But the point is there are a lot of gifts. to wrap. Now, I do enjoy wrapping, but it can get monotonous when you're just like in a fever dream of cutting paper and pulling off pieces of tape. So I like to make it more enjoyable. I feel that way about a lot of potentially annoying things. Do something fun while you're doing something less fun.
especially. Really? Yes. Okay, let's hear it. She sent in an audio clip explaining her holiday gift wrapping tradition. Hey, Jenna and Angela, it's Kendra from the Lazy Genius podcast. Okay, Angela, I heard that you might really like something that I do every Christmas season. So I love giving gifts and we have a large family and I wrap every stocking stuffer because maybe I'm crazy. But the point is there are a lot of gifts. to wrap. Now, I do enjoy wrapping, but it can get monotonous when you're just like in a fever dream of cutting paper and pulling off pieces of tape. So I like to make it more enjoyable. I feel that way about a lot of potentially annoying things. Do something fun while you're doing something less fun.|||尤其是。真的吗？是的。好的，我们听听看。她发来了一段音频剪辑，解释了她自己的节日礼物包装传统。嗨，珍娜和安吉拉，我是来自《懒人天才》播客的肯德拉。好的，安吉拉，我听说你可能会非常喜欢我每年圣诞季都会做的一件事。我非常喜欢送礼物，我们有一个大家庭，而且我会把每一个长筒袜里的填塞小礼物都包起来，可能因为我疯了吧。但重点是，有非常多的礼物要包。现在，我确实挺享受包装礼物的，但当你陷入剪纸和撕胶带的狂热梦境中时，这会变得很单调。所以我喜欢让它变得更有趣。对于许多可能令人烦恼的事情，我都有这种感觉。在做一些不那么有趣的事情时，顺便做点有趣的事。
The fun math is better that way. So here's what I do. Every year when I wrap presents, I watch the entire Lord of the Rings trilogy. It's the only time of the year I watch it. And I look forward to it, kind of to a ridiculous degree every single year. It makes wrapping presents, which sometimes could feel like a chore, especially like when life is busy and the night has finally arrived and like, I just want to relax. But then I remember, oh, wait, I get to be with Aragorn and the rest of them, but really only Aragorn because he's the one I care about. And it just makes this season that much more magical and special because it's the only time
The fun math is better that way. So here's what I do. Every year when I wrap presents, I watch the entire Lord of the Rings trilogy. It's the only time of the year I watch it. And I look forward to it, kind of to a ridiculous degree every single year. It makes wrapping presents, which sometimes could feel like a chore, especially like when life is busy and the night has finally arrived and like, I just want to relax. But then I remember, oh, wait, I get to be with Aragorn and the rest of them, but really only Aragorn because he's the one I care about. And it just makes this season that much more magical and special because it's the only time|||这样算下来快乐的账单更划算。所以我是这么做的。每年我包装礼物时，我都会把《指环王》三部曲完整看一遍。这是我一年中唯一看它的时间。而且我每年都会对此充满期待，甚至达到了荒谬的程度。这让原本有时感觉像是个苦差事的包装礼物——尤其是在生活忙碌、夜晚终于来临、而我只想放松一下的时候——变得不再难熬。但随后我想起：哦，等等，我可以和阿拉贡以及其他人在一起了，不过其实只有阿拉贡，因为他才是我真正在乎的人。这让这个节日季变得更加神奇和特别，因为这是唯一的时间……
I watched those movies. It's just so fun. And a little birdie told me that maybe you would think that idea is fun as well. Happy holidays, ladies. We'll see you soon. Oh, my gosh. Sam and I were literally like air-high-fiving. Like, that is amazing, Kendra.
I watched those movies. It's just so fun. And a little birdie told me that maybe you would think that idea is fun as well. Happy holidays, ladies. We'll see you soon. Oh, my gosh. Sam and I were literally like air-high-fiving. Like, that is amazing, Kendra.|||我观看这些电影。这实在是太有趣了。有个小鸟跟我透露，也许你也会觉得这个主意很有趣。节日快乐，女士们。我们很快再见。哦，天哪。我和萨姆简直在隔空击掌。就像是：太绝了，肯德拉。
That is amazing. Isn't that such a great idea to have this, whatever it is, this movie or this is like a whole movie series. Word Alert. You know it's going to carry you. through all your gift wrapping. I don't think I have enough gift wrapping to get through a trilogy of Lord of the Rings. I mean, also, I have such a new vision of Kendra as she's wrapping a gift for, like, her child and, like, the orcs are like, ah, gah, like, that's amazing.
That is amazing. Isn't such a great idea to have this, whatever it is, this movie or this is like a whole movie series. Word Alert. You know it's going to carry you. through all your gift wrapping. I don't think I have enough gift wrapping to get through a trilogy of Lord of the Rings. I mean, also, I have such a new vision of Kendra as she's wrapping a gift for, like, her child and, like, the orcs are like, ah, gah, like, that's amazing.|||这太棒了。拥有这样一个……无论是什么，这部电影或者这就像是一整部电影系列，难道不是个绝妙的主意吗？词汇警报。你知道它会陪伴你完成所有的礼物包装。我觉得我没有足够多的礼物来包完整整三部《指环王》。我的意思是，另外，我对肯德拉产生了一种崭新的画面感：当她正在为自己的孩子包礼物时，旁边的兽人发出了“啊、尕”的声音，这就太神奇了。
You know, I used to wait on Peter Jackson and Sean Aston and Orlando when they would come back from their breaks. They would come into the restaurant where I worked, like, the restaurant job I still had and I worked for the first season of the office. Kate Manalini. And they would come in at Breck & Meyer. Like, I remember those guys, so funny. I've talked to Sean Aston about this since, but it's so crazy.
You know, I used to wait on Peter Jackson and Sean Aston and Orlando when they would come back from their breaks. They would come into the restaurant where I worked, like, the restaurant job I still had and I worked for the first season of the office. Kate Manalini. And they would come in at Breck & Meyer. Like, I remember those guys, so funny. I've talked to Sean Aston about this since, but it's so crazy.|||你知道，我以前经常服务彼得·杰克逊、肖恩·奥斯汀和奥兰多，当他们休假回来时。他们会来到我工作的餐厅，也就是我在《办公室》第一季时依然在兼职的那家餐厅。凯特·马纳利尼。他们会走进 Breck & Meyer。就像，我记得那些家伙，太搞笑了。我后来跟肖恩·奥斯汀聊过这件事，但真的太疯狂了。
Wow. I'm like, what are you guys doing? They're like, eh, we're filming something in Australia. Filming something. Yeah. What the, I mean? Just a huge, massive trilogy. We don't even know we're making Christmas better, but we're making it better.
Wow. I'm like, what are you guys doing? They're like, eh, we're filming something in Australia. Filming something. Yeah. What the, I mean? Just a huge, massive trilogy. We don't even know we're making Christmas better, but we're making it better.|||哇。我当时问：你们在干嘛？他们说：呃，我们在澳大利亚拍点东西。拍点东西。是的。什么鬼，我的意思是？只是一部宏大、巨型的三部曲。我们当时甚至不知道我们正在让圣诞节变得更好，但我们确实在让它变得更好。
See, that's what I love about the office. Like, people love the office episodes. Like, we really have a contribution to Christmas at our own weird, strange, wonderful way. We do. I've had people tell me, I'm sure you guys have heard this too, that at Christmas time, they rewatch the Office Christmas episodes. Yes. Yeah, there's a DVD with just the just the holidays on it. Oh, I didn't even know that. It came out a while ago. I'm sure you can find it on eBay or something. Really? Where it's just the holiday episodes. Oh, wow. That's pretty smart. I know, right? You know, speaking of like just a compilation like that, so when we were prepping this
瞧，这就是我喜欢《办公室》的原因。比如说，大家都很喜欢《办公室》的剧集。可以说，我们确实以自己这种古怪、奇特、美妙的方式为圣诞节做出了贡献。我们真的是这样。有人对我说——我相信你们也听过这种说法——每到圣诞节，他们就会重温《办公室》的圣诞特别集。对啊。对啊，有一张DVD里只收录了这些节日特辑。哦，我甚至都不知道有这回事。那是很久以前发行的。我相信你在eBay什么的上面一定能找到。真的吗？就只有节日特辑的那种？哦，哇。这挺聪明的。就是说啊！你知道的，说到这种合集类的东西——所以我们在筹备这一期
episode. I was like looking up the different Christmas episodes, just kind of refresh my memory. And there is a compilation on YouTube titled, Are You Ready for This, Michael Scott Ruining the Holidays for 40 Minutes Straight. So if you grab all the moments where Michael Scott is ruining your holiday, it equals 40 minutes. Forty minutes. You can watch all 40 minutes. It's amazing. I would add this. If you're an office fan at the holiday time, if you want to watch 40 minutes of Michael, I'm just going to play you the first minute and a half, just so you get a feel for what you're in for. Okay. Are you ready?
节目的时候，我就会去查阅不同的圣诞节剧集，只是为了唤醒我的记忆。YouTube上有一个合集，标题是——准备好听这个了吗？——《迈克尔·斯科特连续40分钟毁掉节日》。所以，如果你把迈克尔·斯科特毁掉你的节日的那些高光时刻全部剪辑在一起，时长正好是40分钟。40分钟。你可以看整整40分钟。这太棒了。我要补充一点。如果你是《办公室》的粉丝，在节日期间，如果你想看迈克尔发作40分钟，我打算先放给你看头一分半钟，好让你感受一下你将要面对的是什么。好吧。准备好了吗？
Yeah. I'm the real thing. Sit down on my lap and there will be no doubt. Oh, okay. No, it's not, it's not like penis-wise. Christmas is canceled. You can't cancel a holiday. Give it up, Stanley, and you will lose New Year's.
行。我可是货真价实的。坐到我腿上来，那就毫无疑问了。哦，好吧。不，不是的，跟那个“那个”无关。圣诞节取消了。你不能取消一个节日。放弃吧，斯坦利，不然你连新年也没了。
What does that mean? Jim, take New Year's away from Stanley. Michael, what's going on? Carol and I split up amicably. And I just don't think it would be appropriate to celebrate under the circus. Will they still air Rudolph? That's not fair.
这是什么意思？吉姆，把斯坦利的跨年夜取消。迈克尔，怎么回事？卡罗尔和我和平分手了。而且我只是觉得在这种马戏团般的氛围下庆祝并不合适。他们还会播《红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫》吗？这不公平。
Are we going to cancel tonica as well? Fine! Have your party. Just no guests. But we invited guests. Well, you know what, fellas? All of your guests would have probably canceled at the last minute.
我们也要把《托尼卡》取消吗？好吧！你们开你们的派对吧。就是不准有客人。可我们邀请了客人。好吧，你知道吗，伙计们？你们所有的客人都很可能会在最后一分钟取消行程。
Anyway, leaving your life a stupid rotten mess. Okay. Here's Santa! Hey, little girl! What would you like for Christmas? Ooh, you have been a very naughty girl, I see. Michael, we already have a Santa, Phyllis. What the hell is going on?
不管怎样，留给你们的只有一团糟糕的生活。好啦。圣诞老人来了！嘿，小姑娘！你圣诞节想要什么？哦，我看你一直是个非常淘气的女孩呢。迈克尔，我们已经有圣诞老人了，菲利斯。这到底是怎么回事？
Phyllis? Jim, Phyllis is Santa? Yeah. Phyllis. Yeah, I told her a long time ago she could do it. Take it back. That is absurd. No. No!
菲利斯？吉姆，菲利斯是圣诞老人？对啊。菲利斯。对，我很久以前就告诉过她她可以演这个。收回这话。这太荒谬了。不。不！
No! Such a child. That is just a minute and a half. There's 40 minutes of him ruining the holidays. Okay, well, ladies, we also spent a ton of time together on set during the holidays. We would sometimes work right up until the actual real holiday. And we even traded gifts sometimes. And I just thought we could share some of our personal holiday memories that we've spent together over the years.
不！真是个孩子。那才只是一分半钟。这里面有整整40分钟他在毁掉节日。好吧，女士们，我们在片场也曾一起度过了大量节假日。我们有时甚至会一直工作到真正的节日当天。有时我们甚至还会互赠礼物。我想我们可以分享一些我们这些年来一起度过的个人节日回忆。
Well, season one, we didn't make it to Christmas. That's right. Yeah, there was no Christmas episode until season two. But you and I went to the dollar store and got Halloween decorations because we worked until through November. Remember that? Yes, I do. On the trailers?
嗯，第一季的时候，我们没赶上过圣诞节。没错。对，直到第二季才有圣诞特辑。但你和我去了一元店买了万圣节装饰品，因为我们一直工作到11月。还记得吗？是的，我记得。在拖车里？
Yes, we decorated the trailers with little cobwebs and spiders. And then it rained and it was very sad. Yeah, and it was gross. And I think it just like was annoying people because this crap was hanging off their trailers. Take the trash out of the trailers, please, ladies, before you leave. I know. I know. Well, Kate, we were talking about one of the first gifts we got from a cast
对，我们在拖车里挂上了小蜘蛛网和蜘蛛来做装饰。然后天就下雨了，感觉非常凄凉。对，而且很恶心。我觉得这简直是在惹大家生气，因为这些破烂儿都挂在他们的拖车上。请把拖车里的垃圾清理掉，女士们，在你们离开之前。我知道。我知道。好吧，凯特，我们刚才在聊演员送出的第一份礼物，
member, and we thought it was at Christmas, but it was actually a wrap gift that you made. It was, and I'll tell you why. Okay, so this is before you could get anything with the logo that said Dunder Mifflin on it. So I took something off, like a pad off the, or a piece of paper off the set, and I went to Kinko's, and I copied a bunch, and I bought white votive candles, which, you know, I went to 12 years of Catholic school. You guys, I always learned, like, if you want something to work out, you have to pray. So lighting a candle is a wonderful. thing to do. I mean, we do it in the church all the time. So it was an intention candle. And I told everybody. So I literally was up the night before, like, I bought like a case of these white
我们以为那是圣诞节送的，但实际上那是你做的一个杀青礼物。是的，我来告诉你为什么。好吧，当时你还买不到任何印有“邓德米夫林”标志的东西。所以我从片场拿了点东西，比如一个记事本，或者从布景上撕下一张纸，然后我去了金考快印（Kinko's），复印了一大堆，我还买了一些白色的祈愿蜡烛——你知道的，我读了12年天主教学校。你们知道的，我一直受到的教育是，如果你想让某事实现，你就必须祈祷。所以点燃一支蜡烛是一件非常美妙的事情。我是说，我们在教堂里一直这么做。所以那是一支许愿蜡烛。而且我告诉了所有人。所以我真的是在前一天晚上熬夜，比如我买了一整箱这种白色的
votive candles. And I literally just glued the dundermifflin on each one. And I handed it to each person. I didn't wrap it. I just like, here, light it and let it burn. We got to come back next year. We got to come back. Like that was my thing about it. Yeah. I actually still have mine. I have mine. Oh my God. I have mine. I love that you guys saw. Okay. So to me, it's like you just, even if it's not your religion, like I feel like if it brings goodwill and somebody has, you know, an intention that's positive for you, why not? You know, why can't? Kate, after I got my breast cancer diagnosis, before I even had my surgery, I was in that place where I had my diagnosis and I was waiting to start my treatment. I was also raised Catholic.
祈愿蜡烛。然后我真的就在每一根蜡烛上都贴上了邓德米夫林的标签。我把它发给了每个人。我甚至没有包装它。我只是说，给你，点燃它，让它燃烧吧。我们明年必须回来。我们必须回来。这就是我的用意。对。其实我到现在还留着我的那份。我有我的。我的天哪。我有我的。我好喜欢你们还留着。好吧。对我来说，这就好像你只要——即使这不是你的宗教信仰，我也觉得如果它能带来善意，并且有人对你抱有美好的祝愿，为什么不呢？你知道，为什么不能呢？凯特，在我被诊断出乳腺癌之后，甚至在我做手术之前，我正处于那种刚拿到诊断结果、等待开始治疗的阶段。我也是天主教背景下长大的。
I'm not a practicing Catholic anymore, but that stuff doesn't leave you, right? Right. So I went to a little chapel in Santa Fe, New Mexico, where they have the Holy Dirt. Yes. People take pilgrimages from all over the world to this chapel to get this holy dirt. I got the holy dirt. I lit a candle. I prayed to the saint who helps you. St. Jude, who's the patron saint of loss causes. The patron saint of cancer. There's a patron saint of cancer. And now I can't remember his name. So I lit a candle, prayed to the patron saint of cancer, got the dirt. And it was very powerful. And it is in the power of prayer and the power of Ritual. Yes. And something collectively positive. That's really what it is. Just, you know. And so I don't want to take responsibility completely for us coming back season two. But maybe, but maybe your candle. You know, I mean, you know, you guys know, my mom has her Tuesday Bible study and my mom's always like, Angie, want us to pray for anything? And I'm like, yes. And I will call her up with whatever it is. Like when we were going to maybe do this podcast, I was like, mom, Jen and I are taking a big swing here. Can you and the ladies pray? about it. And she was like, well, if you come in agreement with me. So we all, like, I mean, I believe in, I believe in prayer. I do. I do. Even if it's just something you do for yourself. Absolutely. You know, to reset yourself. Kate, you got the office on season two.
我虽然不再是一个虔诚的天主教徒了，但那些东西是不会离开你的，对吧？对的。所以我去了新墨西哥州圣达菲的一个小教堂，那里有“圣土”。是的。世界各地的人们都会朝圣来到这个教堂求取圣土。我拿到了圣土。我点燃了一支蜡烛。我向那位能帮助你的圣人祈祷。圣犹大，他是绝望之事的守护圣人。癌症守护圣人。还有一个癌症守护圣人。现在我想不起他的名字了。所以我点了一支蜡烛，向癌症守护圣人祈祷，拿到了圣土。这非常具有力量。这就是祈祷的力量和仪式的力量。是的。以及某种集体正能量。这其实就是这么回事。只是，你知道的。所以我不想完全把我们第二季能回归归功于我自己。但也许，也许是你的蜡烛。你知道的，我的意思是，你们知道的，我妈妈有她每周二的圣经学习班，我妈妈总是会问：安吉丽娜，你们希望我们为什幺事情祈祷吗？然后我会说：是的。我会把任何事情打电话告诉她。就像我们可能要做这个播客的时候，我就对她说：妈妈，珍和我这次要搞个大动作了。你和女士们能为此祈祷吗？然后她说：好吧，如果你能跟我的意愿达成一致的话。所以我们所有人都，我的意思是，我相信，我相信祈祷。我真的信。我真的信。即使这只是你为自己做的一件事。绝对是的。你知道，为了重置一下你自己。凯特，你们在第二季拿到了《办公室》。
Well, I heard that, but I thought, you know, I'll bet nobody else is going to give this gift. I was trying to be original. So, yeah. And it's true, though, because I think that was the first Dundermifflin anything I have. And that's why we still, we kept them. Yeah. Yeah. It was the first thing with the logo on it. I could probably be arrested if the show didn't go, and I actually created something. No. All right, everybody, I can't believe I'm going to say this, but our time is coming to an end. We have one final question.
好吧，我听说过这个，但我想，你知道的，我敢打赌其他人不会送这个礼物。我当时正试图保持原创。所以，对的。而且确实如此，因为我认为那是我拥有的第一件带有邓德米夫林标志的东西。这就是为什么我们现在依然——我们留着它们。对。对。那是第一件带有标志的东西。如果这部剧没有续订，而我又确实是原创了某些东西的话，我大概会被捕吧。不。好了，各位，我简直不敢相信我要说这话，但我们的时间快要结束了。我们还有一个最后一个问题。
What? I didn't even get to talk about being dragged into rehab by Michael Scott. Oh, well, wait, that's, but that's, please. Please, wait, wait. Before we get to our final question, will you please discuss being dragged into rehab by Michael Scott? It's truly a brilliant scene, Kate. You are brilliant in it. All the trash.
什么？我甚至都还没机会聊聊被迈克尔·斯科特强行拖去戒疗所的事呢！哦，好吧，等等，那是，但那是，请。请，等等，等等。在我们进入最后一个问题之前，你能聊聊被迈克尔·斯科特强行拖去戒疗所的经历吗？这真的是个绝妙的场面，凯特。你在里面的表现太棒了。所有的垃圾。
Oh, my gosh. That was one of the only... Okay, so in Moroccan Christmas, when Michael Scott pretends like he's taking Meredith to get a drink at a bar, but instead drags her to rehab, that whole scene in the parking lot was completely improvised. That's the only completely improvised scene I got to do on the show. And I feel like not a lot of us had an opportunity to do that. And I think the intention was, because I think Paul Feig was a director, they were going to do like a voiceover over the whole thing. So I don't know if they even intended on keeping it. Right.
哦，天哪。那是仅有的几个……好吧，所以在《摩洛哥圣诞节》里，当迈克尔·斯科特假装带梅雷迪思去酒吧喝一杯，但实际上却把她拖到戒疗所时，停车场里的那一整场戏完全是即兴发挥的。那是我在剧中唯一经历的完全即兴的戏份。我觉得我们当中没有多少人有机会做到这一点。而且我觉得当时本来的意图是——因为保罗·费格（Paul Feig）是导演——他们打算在整场戏上配上旁白。所以我不知道他们是否真的打算保留它。对的。
We're not going to use this dialogue, say whatever you want. Right. But they ended up using a lot of it, which I was like, I can't really about. But I just remember also there were two stunt people dressed like us, like Michael Scott and Meredith, out of the corner of my eye, just in case one of us got hurt. Because we really didn't plan what we were doing. The chase was not really planned. I mean, I knew he was going to throw trash cans at me. Oh, I was throwing trash cans at him.
我们不会用这段对话，你们想说什么就说什么。对的。但他们最后还是用了很大一部分，当时我想，我其实并没有想那么多。但我还记得当时还有两个特技演员打扮成我们俩的样子——迈克尔·斯科特和梅雷迪思——就在我的眼角余光里，以防我们俩有谁受伤。因为我们真的没有计划我们在做什么。追逐戏其实并不是计划好的。我是说，我知道他会朝我扔垃圾桶。哦，是我在朝他扔垃圾桶！
What am I saying? But it was all like a weird. we had this whole negotiation and running thing. And I was screaming so much, literally when he was dragging me, once we got into the hospital, Kelly Cantley was the attendant at the rehab center. That's right. Our assistant director played that.
我到底在说什么呀？但这完全就像是一种奇怪的……我们有这样一整套讨价还价和奔跑的桥段。而且我尖叫得太厉害了，真的，当他拖着我的时候，一旦我们进了医院，凯利·坎特利（Kelly Cantley）就是戒疗所的服务人员。没错。我们的助理导演扮演的那个角色。
First AD, and it was the only time I think she's ever been on an episode. And I literally lost my voice by the end of that. And it was totally worth it. It was totally worth it. But that whole thing where I'm negotiating or Meredith's saying like, wait, wait, wait, wait a minute. Totally. I was like, I was so happy that Paul Feig,
第一副导演，而且那好像是她唯一一次客串出演一集。到最后我嗓子都快哑了。不过这绝对值得。这绝对值得。但整个那段我在讲条件，或者说梅雷迪思在说“等等，等等，等等，等等”的戏。完全是。我当时想，我太高兴保罗·费格了，
he's like, do that again. He kept asking me to repeat certain things that I would say. I'm like, oh, so, yeah, I just saw Paul Feig last week at a women in film event. And we were just, like, you know, just totally reminiscing about how wonderful it was to work together on the office. Yeah. But aren't you so thankful of all the directors, it was Paul Feig? Because, of course, Paul gave you all of that agency to just, like, go for it. And then he supported you when you found a nugget that was really good.
他当时说：再演一遍。他一直让我重复我说过的一些特定的话。我想，哦，所以，是的，我上周在“影视女性”活动上刚见过保罗·费格。我们俩就在那里，你知道的，完全在重温我们在《办公室》一起工作是多么的美好。对的。难道你不觉得特别感激所有的导演里恰好是保罗·费格吗？因为当然啦，保罗给了你们所有人那种可以放手去做的自主权。然后当你找到了一个真的很棒的灵感时，他又会支持你。
Totally. All right. Are we ready for our final question? Yeah, here it is. If you had to attend one Dunder Mifflin holiday party, which one would you pick? And now we're going to give you the choices. We're going to give you the choices. But basically, you're looking at a party either thrown by Angela, Pam, Phyllis, Jim and Dwight are Andy. Jenna, why don't you list them off? Here they are. Would you want to go to Christmas party? Angela's in charge of Christmas, and you're going to have a real sad Yankee swap. Do you want to attend a Benny Hanuk Christmas. This is the dueling Christmas parties. You have Pam and Karen versus Angela. Marocan Christmas. This is the one that Phyllis is in charge of. This ends in Meredith's intervention. And burnt hair. And yes. Hair on fire. Yeah. While she's belly dancing. Thank you. There's also secret Santa. This was Jim and Dwight's holiday party. We had dueling Santas. You had both Phyllis and Michael as Santa and Michael as Jesus.
完全赞同。好了。我们准备好迎接最后一个问题了吗？好，题目是这样的：如果你必须参加一个邓德米夫林的节日派对，你会选哪一个？现在我们要给出选项了。我们要给出选项了。但基本上，你要考虑的派对是由安吉丽娜、帕姆、菲利斯、吉姆和德怀特或者安迪举办的。珍娜，你为什么不把它们列举出来呢？它们在这里。你想去圣诞派对吗？安吉丽娜负责圣诞节，而且你会经历一场真正让人扫兴的“礼物大盗”（Yankee Swap）交换游戏。你想参加班尼哈娜圣诞节吗？这是两个圣诞派对打擂台。有帕姆和凯伦对阵安吉丽娜。摩洛哥圣诞节。这是由菲利斯负责的那一场。这场派对以对梅雷迪思的干预治疗告终。还有烧焦的头发。是的。头发着火了。对的。当她在跳肚皮舞的时候。谢谢。还有秘密圣诞老人。这是吉姆和德怀特的节日派对。我们有两个圣诞老人打擂台。你既有菲利斯扮演的圣诞老人，又有迈克尔扮演的圣诞老人，还有迈克尔扮演的耶稣。
I was sitting on Phyllis's lap when Kevin was sitting on Michael Scott. slap at the same time. Oh, that's so great. So great. Trying not to laugh. You could attend a classy Christmas. This is when Pam was in charge of a regular Christmas that got turned into a bigger, fancier party to impress Holly. Michael has kind of a meltdown, and there's the insane snowball fight with Jim and Dwight. There's Christmas wishes. Andy's in charge of Christmas. Dwight and Jim prank each other. Robert California announces his divorce. That's always fun at a party. Or, finally, Dwight's Christmas, he throws the traditional shrewd holiday party with bell schnickle. And you are either impish or admirable.
我当时正坐在菲利斯的腿上，而凯文同时坐在迈克尔·斯科特的腿上。哦，太棒了。太棒了。努力憋住不笑。你可以参加一场高档圣诞节。这是帕姆负责的一个普通圣诞节，结果变成了一个更盛大、更高级的派对，为了给霍莉留下好印象。迈克尔情绪有点崩溃，还有吉姆和德怀特之间疯狂的打雪仗。还有圣诞愿望。安迪负责圣诞节。德怀特和吉姆互相恶作剧。罗伯特·加利福尼亚宣布离婚。派对上有这个总是很有趣。或者，最后，德怀特的圣诞节，他举办传统的精明节日派对，有黑面神（Belsnickel）。而你要么表现得顽皮，要么表现得讨人喜欢。
And you get swatted at with a bunch of sticks. Which Christmas party would you like to attend? Well, this is like picking your favorite child. You really cannot do it. Can you? It's really just. I don't know. Some of these children are much worse than the others.
然后你会被一束树枝抽打。你想参加哪个圣诞派对？好吧，这就像是在选你最喜欢的孩子一样。你真的做不到。对吧？这真的只是……我不知道。其中有些孩子可比其他的糟糕多了。
But I will actually say, I had the most. fun shooting Moroccan Christmas, but I will say a Christmas party, the first one, was my favorite because we were in New Territory for the show, for Dunner-R-Mill. It was just, it was just, you know, remember, the big tree that didn't fit? Yes, they had to get the biggest tree. And then the Yankee Swap, which was endless but fantastic. That group scene, yeah. There was like a, like a, like a, like a, like a, like a, like a, like a, the weight of a brick. Like, that's how old this episode is. I know, the old took. I'm with you, Kate. I'm with you because I felt like that group scene of us all in a circle handing out the gifts is one of my favorite group scenes we ever did on the show. Everyone had a
但我实际上要说的是，拍摄《摩洛哥圣诞节》时我玩得最开心，但我还是要说，第一场圣诞派对是我的最爱，因为对于这部剧来说，对于邓德米夫林来说，我们在探索新的领域。那真的，真的，你知道的，还记得吗，那棵尺寸不合的大树？对，他们非得弄一棵最大的树。然后是“礼物大盗”游戏，虽然没完没了但太棒了。那个群戏，对的。当时有一种，就像那种，那种，就像那种，那种砖头般的重量。我是说，这集都这么老了。我懂，年代久远。我跟你意见一致，凯特。我跟你一样，因为我觉得我们所有人围成一圈分发礼物的那个群戏，是我在剧中做过的最喜欢的群戏之一。每个人都有一个
moment and it was just amazing. I'm going to go another way, guys. Where are you going? I'm going with a Benihana Christmas, the dueling Christmas parties. I just loved, because we had the singing and everything, and I loved that in the conference room. Pam and Karen had booze. It was, yeah, it was like two parties. You can go to two parties. But Angela had, I think, some good food. You had some good, like, treats and cookies and things.
高光时刻，简直太棒了。我要选另一个，伙计们。你选哪个？我选班尼哈娜圣诞节，也就是两个圣诞派对打擂台的那集。我之所以喜欢，是因为我们有唱歌之类的环节，而且我喜欢在会议室里的那个场景。帕姆和凯伦有酒喝。那是，对的，就像有两个派对。你可以去两个派对。但安吉丽娜那边的食物好像挺不错的。有一些很棒的美食、饼干之类的好东西。
Yeah. So I don't know. If I had to attend a party just as a guest, I think I might like to show up at the dueling Christmas parties. If I had to go back in time and re-experience shooting a Christmas episode, then I think, gosh, that's very difficult. But then I'd have to go to the original Christmas party. Okay, so same.
所以，我不知道。如果我仅仅作为一名客人去参加一个派对，我想我可能会想出现在“两个圣诞派对打擂台”的那一场。如果我必须回到过去，重新体验拍摄一集圣诞特辑，那么我想，天哪，这太难了。但那样的话我必须去最初的那场圣诞派对。好吧，所以一样。
So if me, Angela, me, Kinsey, Martin, wanted to revisit, it would be Yankee Swap because I just want to live in that group scene again, just selfishly. But if I'm just a partygoer, I think I would pick Secret Santa because I love the idea of two Santas in just. Jesus all at the same party. Yeah, that sounds like a great party. That was my runner-up. Right. I'm still like, I think Meredith is all in for the first Christmas episode, and so is Kate. Well, Kate, thank you so much for being on our holiday chit-chat episode. The folks at Macy sent a gift card for you. They sure did. Here you go, Kate. Happy shopping from the folks at Macy's. Thank you so much, Macy's. I didn't get you anything. I'm so sorry. I feel really, I didn't buy Macy's anything.
所以如果我——安吉丽娜，我，金西·马丁——想要重温的话，那会是“礼物大盗”，因为我只想出于一己私利再次活在那个群戏场景里。但如果我只是一个派对常客，我想我会选择“秘密圣诞老人”，因为我喜欢那种在同一个派对上有两个圣诞老人以及……耶稣都在的想法。对，听起来像个绝妙的派对。那是我的第二选择。好嘞。我还是觉得，我觉得梅雷迪思对第一场圣诞派对情有独钟，凯特也是。好吧，凯特，非常感谢你能来参加我们的节日闲聊特辑。梅西百货的人为你准备了一张礼品卡。他们确实准备了。给你，凯特。祝梅西百货的各位购物愉快。非常感谢，梅西百货。我什么都没给你买。我很抱歉。我真的觉得，我没给梅西买任何东西。
So sorry. Oh, Kate, this is so fun. So fun. I mean, Kate, I do kind of feel like I need you to lead us in a Christmas carol. Yes. Are they free? Can we have one? I know a bunch that are free.
非常抱歉。哦，凯特，这太有趣了。太有趣了。我是说，凯特，我确实觉得我需要你带头给我们唱一首圣诞颂歌。好的。它们是免费的吗？我们能来一个吗？我知道很多免费的。
You know so? I'm trying to think of like something from the office. And the only thing I can think of is come they told me by rapa, da da da da da da. That was still an Angela's song. Thank you guys. And thank you to the folks at Macy's for supporting office ladies. We love these holiday bonus episodes. We love you guys.
你知道吗？我在努力想一些来自《办公室》的东西。我能想到的只有“快来听他们告诉我，通过拉帕，达哒哒哒哒哒……”那依然是一首安吉丽娜的歌。谢谢你们，伙计们。也感谢梅西百货支持《办公室女士》播客。我们超爱这些节日彩蛋特辑。我们爱你们。
Kate, thanks for coming in. Thank you so much, you guys. I love you, Angela. Yes. You guys. And can we, are we going to sing our way out of this or what? Okay. Oh, come let us adore him.
凯特，谢谢你来作客。非常感谢你们，伙计们。我爱你，安吉丽娜。是的。伙计们。我们是不是要边唱边退场，还是怎么着？好吧。哦，来吧，让我们崇拜他。
Oh, come let us adore him. Oh, come let us adore him. Mr. Michael Scott. Boy, would Michael have loved that. He would have. Perfect. Happy holidays, everybody. Happy holidays. Happy holidays.
哦，来吧，让我们崇拜他。哦，来吧，让我们崇拜他。迈克尔·斯科特先生。天哪，迈克尔肯定会喜欢这个的。他绝对会喜欢的。太完美了。祝大家节日快乐！节日快乐。节日快乐。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley-Eanzeley. Bubbleco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rupertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）出品的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉丽娜·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·伊安兹利（Ainsley-Eanzeley）Bubbleco。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特树》（Rupertree）。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。